[Music]
because I've developed a fairly sizable
following over the last decade in
YouTube and then in social media I wind
up getting a lot of comments that are
essentially unsolicited advice and so
I'm shooting this dr. Sadler responds
video as a way of providing a sort of
common answer to all of these instances
but also to help people you know reflect
on what they're doing as they're giving
that advice is it a good idea is it a
bad idea why is that the case
and so maybe you know if I'm posting
this as a response to you you might want
to watch on and think over the things
that I had to say obviously if you're
just stumbling across this it may not
apply to you but you could find it
interesting anyway so what are the
things that people give me advice about
you know a good bit of it has to do with
content that I'm producing and the ways
in which it's being produced or how it's
being done and I want to put aside you
know the request for can you do content
on this and this and this I've already
addressed that in another response video
so I don't mean those sort of questions
or comments instead I have in mind the
sorts of things where people complain
because I'm standing in front of the
chalkboard and they can't see at any
given point in time exactly what's on
the track board or they're saying you
know I don't like the 45 second intro to
your core concept videos or the sound
quality needs to get boosted where am i
core things along those lines another
kind of advice that I get quite a bit of
and this tends to be in in social media
although I do get some of it on my
videos if I talk about you know related
things is within the realm of what you
can call health and fitness bodily so
you know I get people telling me how I
ought to exercise or what exercises I
have to be doing or not doing and what
diet I should be taking or not taking
and what supplements and all that sort
of thing then the third thing would be
mental health and relationships people
give me a good bit of advice about that
sort of area of my life as well so I'm
going to talk about each of these three
in turn but first I want to sort of set
out a general you might call it dynamic
the sort of thinking things to think
about reflections so you're giving me
advice now ask yourself do you actually
know me the do we have a relationship if
not then how do you know that the advice
that you're giving is actually on point
you might say well I represent a whole
bunch of other people who think the same
way
there's a lot of people who think that
but it's not usually the case I mean
you'd have to do like a study in order
to be able to back that up and typically
it tends to be more anecdotal and you
know a lot of confirmation bias sort of
things doing that you might be the only
person complaining about something and
wanting it changed so you know you
probably would want to think about that
first and you know ask yourself what are
you actually trying to accomplish in
giving advice is this a knee-jerk
reaction that's probably not a good way
to live out your life in the digital
landscape you know just responding to
things without even really thinking
about it that's poor impulse control
that's not a philosophical rational life
which is really what my channel is about
isn't it yeah I'm a philosophy professor
I help people understand how to live a
more rational measured proportional life
using ancient and medieval and modern
philosophy so it'd be a little bit in
Congress wouldn't it are you in in in
you know giving advice are you really
being kind of passive aggressive or
complaining about things are you trying
to draw attention to yourself
are you're trying to make a name to
boost your brand in some way these are
all things you you probably want to
think about
and at first of course nobody's going to
say yes that's exactly what I'm doing
you know you think it through it's kind
of a strange thing to do to give nearly
absolute strangers advice maybe you do
that in other places maybe you're the
kind of person who on a train or
airplane or you know in an uber or
something just constantly provides other
people advice and you know maybe that
works for you maybe that doesn't you I
don't know you so I won't presume to
give you advice about that other than to
say that you should probably think about
it so let's talk about those three
different main venues of advice giving
that that I tend to get so the biggest
thing is content right and videos are
probably the largest things I've done so
many of them as a matter of fact this is
something you probably want to keep in
mind I've been creating video content on
YouTube now for nine years I've been
teaching in the classroom for 20 years
so I probably have some reason for why I
do things the way I do and I you know
I've developed a lot of good practices
when it comes to it there's a time thing
involved in some of the advice if you're
commenting on a video from 2012 and
saying that the Lighting's not great or
that the sound you know needs to be
improved and I should use a mic
you're coming hang out and video from
2012 I got a mic matter of fact here it
is right here
and you can see it on more recent videos
so you commenting and saying on an older
video that I should get a mic just kind
of shows ignorance on your part and does
not reflect well on you doesn't
certainly doesn't make me want to
interact with you on things or take
advice from you so you know advice needs
to be wit really well grounded in
research or at least some you know
minimal due diligence but there's other
things too I mean here's where I invite
you to think about why you would want to
give the advice that you do let's take
the 45 second intros
two core concept videos now some people
will once a month generally somebody
else chime in and say you really should
get rid of that I've heard it so many
times yeah you've heard it so many times
you're not the only viewer I I get you
know about it at least you know 1,300
new subscribers each month presumably
they haven't seen all the videos that
you've seen or if they have certainly
haven't gotten worked up about it and
decided that it needs to you know you
have a different intro or something like
that I mean you know there's a remedy
for for not wanting to watch that or
listen to that 45 seconds there's this
cool feature in YouTube both mobile and
on the desktop where you can like you
can move ahead in the video all by
yourself if that really bothers you why
not do that all right take it take
matters into your own hands it's it's so
easy to do
the same thing goes for being in front
of my chalkboard you know if you can't
see exactly what's written on the board
at point a you can move ahead to another
point in the video where I'm not
standing in front of it you don't have
to to make that into a comment that you
want to have a conversation about it's
kind of a weird thing to do and so
here's there's there's other things that
people complain about as well or give
advice about but I'm just going to put
that aside and I'm gonna invite you to
think about this this interesting
feature of modern life so we have the
internet really great isn't it to have
that you know on mobile technology and
all that and then we have this this
portion of the internet that we call
YouTube that it's pretty vast and
there's a lot of great cool stuff there
and then we have the portion that's my
channel and that's you know devoted to
helping people understand philosophy my
videos by design are a little bit longer
and I go more into depth and I don't put
a really high emphasis on high
production or anything like that it's
not a glitzy channel but the people who
watch my channel think that it's you
know one of the better ones when it
comes to actually presenting ideas
correctly
and sympathetically so now think about
the fact that you want things to be
different than they are first off are
you are you bankrolling the channel I'm
watching it in the advertisement now
that your advertisement doesn't pay for
anything and YouTube serves ads whether
I monetize videos or not so put the @
aside right are you you know does it
really make sense for you to say to
somebody who's providing quality content
for free you should be doing it
differently why should I be doing it
differently because you want me to do it
differently you know you may be the one
person who's asking for them or maybe
you represent a thousand people so what
there's a hundred thousand people who'd
like to see it done the way that it's
being done because they're watching it
and you know you're also getting
something for free so it's it's a little
bit you know it's a little bit of a sign
of ingratitude or however you want to
put it whatever whatever motivation it's
coming from to be complaining about
things and demanding that they be
different because you want them to be
done a different way now you know if you
want to Commission me to do a video in a
certain way you can certainly do that
but that's an email to me that's not a
comment that's you reaching out to me
and me providing you with a price sheet
or something like that so these are all
things to keep in mind let's talk now
about health and fitness so you know I
post things from me being at the gym and
sometimes what I'm cooking or what we're
doing and stuff like that
and I do get quite a few people who
think that it's their business to tell
me what sort of exercises I should or
shouldn't be doing and what sort of diet
I should be on and all that sort of
stuff and if you think about this it's
really kind of irrational to do that to
begin with if you're not a you know
dietician or nutritionist or somebody
who actually specializes in this stuff
why would I want to hear from you
because you know you want on a diet and
it worked for you or your aunt Belinda
did or something like that that's purely
anecdotal right or because you know
you're into certain kinds of exercise I
should be I mean people who are into
CrossFit are kind of fanatics about that
to the point that we make jokes about it
right just like you know the vegans as
well right
vegan crossfitter and pick whoever else
you want walk into a bar how do you know
they all tell you so the thing is that
they want everybody else to be doing
that kind of exercise but you ask
yourself why we all have different
bodies you know this is part of why we
we go to professionals to help us you
know trainers trainers have different
things for different people if if one
trainer is giving everybody the same
advice that's a terrible trainer and
don't go to them because they don't know
what they're doing they're their hack
it's got to be tailored to the person
and it's got to be welcomed to the
person if if I'm not soliciting advice
from you and I'm just saying hey did my
and my workout today here's the playlist
from you know my classic metal
collection that I listen to and here's a
picture of me at the Wisconsin Athletic
Club I'm not inviting you to tell me why
lifting free weights is better than
doing machines or why I should be doing
kettlebells or why I should be doing
yoga that sort of stuff
it's not being asked of you and so
listen so you want to think to yourself
what am I getting out of this why am i
pushing this particular program for
somebody who I don't know that in cases
where it might actually be
counterproductive for them to do what
they're they're you know being advised
to do by by me because I want to stick
my nose in we can say similar things
about mental health and relationships
even more so really because we all have
different bodies and there are some
things you know in common like don't
drink mercury that's that's bad for
everybody but you know whether you do
this regime or this regime or this
regime that really has to be tailored
similar for mental health you know some
people they need medication other people
don't some people benefit from certain
kinds of therapy
other people needs other kinds of
therapy sometimes it's difficult to find
good good therapists in the area that
you want to do stuff on you really
shouldn't give people mental health
advice unless you actually have some
training in the area and even then you
probably want to be kind of kind of
leery about going beyond generalizations
so you know when I post for example
videos that in which I mention that I've
struggled with depression and I found
you know certain areas of philosophy
helpful with that or doing exercise has
been helpful or any of those sorts of
things I'm not looking for you to tell
me what you think I ought to be doing
that's kind of silly isn't it you're not
my therapist and you don't actually know
me even though you may feel that you do
from watching some videos you don't know
me well enough to be able to provide
that sort of advice and the same thing
goes for you know relationships what I
want to do with my wife or my kids or
you know job situation or any of that
sort of stuff that's not really up to
you unless you know me quite well and if
I want your advice
I'm already soliciting it on those those
manners so I again I invite you to think
about why you would think it's a good
idea to give people unsolicited advice
about these sorts of matters what what
are you getting out of it what is the
payoff for you I don't know I don't know
what it is because I don't know you but
that's that's the long and short of it
those are the three main areas where
people do it this is one of those if the
shoe fit where is it sort of videos so
it might it may not apply to some of you
and some of you as you're watching it if
you've got to this point you might say
oh yeah yeah I'm doing that and again I
really invite you to use this as an
opportunity for thinking about your own
thought processes and your own
assumptions and and you know your choice
to provide other people with unsolicited
advice might be something good to look
at and think about
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]